hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today features an all-out bout
between beantown's best box office
behemoths and while that was like eight
b words in a row we're talking two
a-listers here matt affleck and ben
david that's not right it's uh
matt damon versus ben affleck and
hunting season is officially open
[Music]
applesauce
in one corner you have a hollywood
megastar and in the other it's also a
hollywood megastar these two lads have
taken over tinseltown in a variety of
ways acting writing directing producing
and most importantly getting their
picture taken while almost never
spilling a sip of precious dunkin donuts
coffee but they started out as two utes
who lived a block away from each other
in cambridge massachusetts hey that's
where smack kids go to college one would
go on to play a super spy janitor whose
poker addiction traps him behind enemy
lines in world war ii the other would
feature as a bank robbing bully who uses
every bat gadget on his utility belt to
save the world from an asteroid okay i
may have watched way too many damon and
affleck movies this week so while i
unjumble their filmography you get to
see how we'll determine a winner round
one box office round two tomato meter
slash audience score round three best
characters round four iconic moments and
then we'll do a wild card round to
settle the score once and for all or at
least until another bourne movie gets
greenlit or bennifer decide to complete
their classic trilogy hey is that the
ben affleck in the ocean's eleven no
that's his brother but matt damon's also
look there's a whole lot of famous
people that uh talk like this and would
refer to me as uh mac and with that it's
time to our go to the first round let's
get it on well my daddy was here today
hey tell me to sit on down and leave the
yak into the college boys so round one
box office to know matt damon and ben
affleck is to love them or at least fork
over some cash to see their movies ever
since their surprise independent film
smash hit goodwill hunting did 226
million dollars of worldwide box office
business in 1997 the duo have been
household names and main attractions at
the cineplex though their career arcs
have been slightly different over the
course of 37 movies ben affleck flicks
have generated 5.35
billion dollars across the globe making
for a perfect average of 145 million
dollars those digits were no doubt aided
by gigantic michael bay blockbusters
like armageddon and pearl harbor oh and
did i mention he was in a couple of them
superhero movies that the kids just love
these days almost two decades after
saving the world and falling in love
with bruce willis and steven tywer's
love child ben put on the legendary cape
and cow as batman in zack snyder's dc
universe batman v superman hey that's
kind of like our show and justice league
teamed up to ring up over 1.5 billion
dollars in global cash register noises
when you toss in famous roles like jack
ryan in the summer of all fears and
daredevil in the well accurately titled
daredevil plus high profile turns in
gone girl and argo it almost seems
unfair to put that damon kid down the
street up against ben
or is it matt damon may have had to wait
five years longer than ben to be named
people's sexiest blake shelton of the
year but if we're counting money at the
movies matt damon's ford might just
outrun affleck's ferrari to date damon's
43 worldwide theatrical releases have
deposited a total of 8.34 billion
dollars into a bank that i hope isn't
located in uh charlestown massachusetts
that makes for an average of 190 million
dollars per movie damon makes good
cinema that the people want to see the
martian and saving private ryan a loan
account for over one billion dollars
worth of business and teaming up the
great wall in the departed give him
another 500 million bucks
really the great wall
really
all right to each their own matt damon
also no stranger to those bigger
franchises as well he's got the danny
ocean trilogy and the jason bourne
quadrilogy and they combine for around
2.5 billion across the globe
matt and ben obviously both get the same
amount of credit for goodwill hunting
and the later kevin smith films and fine
i'll be nice and add on 15 million
dollars to each of their totals thanks
to school ties even if we toss in the
movie directed by affleck that he wasn't
in gone baby gone matt damon still
enjoys a sizable advantage at the ticket
booth here's a fun fact you can try on
your friends later ben affleck has had
14 movies across the 100 million dollar
mark at the worldwide box office matt
damon higher or lower it's way higher 30
movies for maddie ball game affleck is
certainly in the lineup but it is damon
that's batting cleanup in this round
david webb which is jason bourne's real
name beats bruce wayne which is batman's
real name in round one and it's an early
1-0 lead for team damon
i'm pumped let's let the healing begin
round two tomato meter slash audience
score okay maybe more tickets have been
sold on account of matt damon movies but
now it's time to see how the critics and
audiences felt after they forked over
their hard-earned cash who caused more
buyers remorse folks let's be honest you
don't come here for my good looks sure
it's nice icing on the cake but the real
reason you all tune in is to be reminded
of some incredible celebrity low lights
well you're in luck because in this
episode we got the guy from geely and
the dude from downsizing but first let's
be fair and celebrate their big wins
matt damon the honor is yours so in good
will hunting matt plays a janitor at mit
but now his top 10 movies on the tomato
meter have earned such high marks he
could probably get into mit goodwill
hunting part one is his all-time highest
on the tomato meter at 98 percent and
you got to go all the way down to his
10th highest film to find a movie in the
80s that's contagion at 85
in between you'll discover franchise
fare like the born ultimatum at 92
percent high-profile projects like
behind the candelabra at 94 percent and
the hilarious musical and or comedy the
martian at 91
ah the golden globes the award show that
keeps us all in stitches ben affleck
also has a slew of flicks in freshville
and he totals five the top 90 on the
tomato meter goodwill hunting is at the
top of his list as well at 98
then we have his star director turn argo
at 96 percent another star director turn
with the town at 92 percent and
shakespeare and love also clocking in at
92 percent and also at 92 percent you've
waited long enough for it to come up
dazed and confused he doesn't have the
biggest role in richard linklater's
seminal cult classic but he's
nevertheless memorable as the bully who
gets his comeuppance from above and
thinks deep purple rocks a sentiment we
can all get behind
you hear me you're dead
so now let's go below because as i
hinted at both of our competitors today
have had some less than great offerings
damon's made some bad movies but affleck
has some all-timers gilly clocks in at
six percent on the tomato meter and
other notable misfires would be
surviving christmas at seven percent and
reindeer games at 24
some people just do not do well around
the holidays but i will defend ben
affleck because runner runner is at
seven percent but he was good in it and
13
there's phantoms in which he was the
bomb yo i can also defend some rotten
movies from matt damon like the legend
of bagger advance at 43
and happy feet two at 45
come on my niece and nephews love it but
he's also got the great wall at 35
suburbicon is his record low at 28
and monuments men is at 30 percent quick
side note monuments men is the worst
kind of rotten movie because the cast is
incredible the premise is awesome and
it's just so
boring at least reindeer games had a
pulse do better monument collectors when
it comes to tomato meter averages it's
once again matt damon who enjoys a
decisive advantage his movies all
combined for a fresh average of 67
while ben affleck's total average is a
competitive but rotten 54
his only hope now is the audience score
and
it's not looking good but it's closer
maul rats and chasing amy both enjoy
audience score totals of 82 percent and
83 respectively and zack snyder's
justice league 94
i personally still prefer zack snyder's
talking owl movie but i'm happy for
batman matt damon remains rock solid on
the audience score but he's got a new
high mark movie goodwill hunting is 94
percent but it's surpassed by saving
private ryan at 95 percent and the
standard setting ford v ferrari at 98
that's kind of like our show i did that
joke already
still plays damon's audience score
average is still fresh it's 66 percent
and afflex is closer but still rotten 57
so despite being game competition
through two rounds matt damon has jumped
out to a two to nothing lead
i can't stay down here alfred round
three best characters
so matt damon has an impressive lead and
a win is within his grasp but both he
and ben are huge red sox fans and once
upon a time the sox were down to the
yankees three nothing in the alcs and
well they made a movie about it fever
pitch underrated anywho matt is coming
off another victorious round and so he
again gets to go first because bagger
vance is like golf and the honor
although the role of bagger vance was
actually played by will smith not matt
damon so what great characters has matt
done well would start with two very
smart occasionally violent fellas by the
name of will hunting and jason bourne
they're so great they had movies named
after him will hunting still endures
today as a man child who needs less of a
gentle nudge and more of a strong safety
forearm shiver in the right direction
sure the movie belongs to will but the
standouts in that flick are bearded
robin williams who won an oscar for his
role as psychiatrist sean minnie drivers
will's love interest and that affleck
dude but the bourne identity that was a
whole bunch of matt some more mad and
some fake passports with matt damon's
picture on him there's obviously
tremendous supporting roles by a variety
of award-winning performers in that
franchise but damon proved his franchise
ability did i just make up a really cool
word i've never heard it before by being
so watchable throughout his four film
run as the super spy speaking of movies
named after them he was also the guy
from the title and the talented mr
ripley and before we abandoned franchise
mode completely i will point out he's
played loki twice one version in dogma
and another in thor ragnarok albeit he
eats it in both movies but he's
reportedly back for another try in thor
love and thunder come on matt third
time's a charm damon was pulling off
other famous roles like mike mcdermott
in rounders and linus caldwell in
ocean's 11 while his buddy ben was busy
becoming the biggest a-lister in the
world hot off of goodwill hunting where
his chucky is definitely a scene stealer
more on that in the next round affleck
would go on to hold his own against a
phenomenal earth-saving cast as aj frost
and armageddon and he remained very
engaging even in the meh pearl harbor in
doing my exhausting research for this
episode i did find myself responding to
his earlier roles such as holden mcneil
and chasing amy the dick at the mall and
mall rats and obviously o'banion
enthazed and confused and while there
may be a world where obanian and will
hunting could have gotten arrested
together o'banion and matt damon's evil
bully character from school ties they
definitely post very controversial stuff
on facebook
but while matt damon was coasting along
in the 2000s taking roles in high
profile projects like the departed ben
affleck was cast as something of a
hollywood icarus he flew too close to
the sun too early and appeared to be
ready to flame out then he began a long
rebuilding process taking on the role of
actual superman george reeves in
hollywoodland now that was never
intended to be a blockbuster but
hollywood land at least reminded folks
that ben affleck can act and yes before
he played batman he did play the real
life actor who was the original soups
george reeves and yes there's a scene in
that film where he's in bed with diane
lane who would go on to play martha kent
superman's mom and worlds are colliding
george is upset
this of course led to a resurgence in
a-list status both in front of and
behind the camera as he directed himself
to much acclaim in flicks like argo and
the town although the reaction was a bit
mixed when he was announced as the new
bruce wayne bat guy however once fans
saw him on the big screen they were
pretty cool with it and they might want
some more okay time for a quick
head-to-head matchup who plays real life
people better matt damon can cite folks
like francois paneer and invictus and
carol shelby from ford v ferrari affleck
encounter with reeves tony mendez from
argo and aj frost from armagedd
wait that that didn't happen
not based on a true story
well i've been lied to my whole life
i tell you you guys really can't pick
them
this guy is as smart as he is ruthless
playing pretend is what these fellas do
best and as much as i admire matt damon
for his incredible work in the martian
as potato enthusiast mark watney i'm
leaning towards affleck in this round
the guy's proven he can step into a
gigantic franchise and elevate the
ensemble but he can also star in more
intimate dramatic fare some of which he
even directs himself it's not a question
of who's the better thespian because
they're both great but of the characters
they have portrayed and if there's a
tiebreaker it's gonna go to ben
affleck's alcoholic basketball coach who
puts his beers in the freezer in advance
to ensure maximum coldness the same way
your uncle mark does
do not try that stunt at home kids i'm a
trained professional ben gets on the
scoreboard and cuts the lead in half
it's boston guy 2 other boston guy won i
will go thanks a lot
yes i have the flaw now um
round four iconic moments
well if you just won a best character
round you're feeling pretty good about
your chances in another segment that
puts a premium on cool stuff your
characters did while they were on screen
batman jack ryan the kid hooked on
steroids in an after school special
affleck is going to be a force to be
reckoned with here but that's matt damon
on the other end of the ledger and he
plays jason bourne and watch this punch
actually that scene played out as
something of a disappointment once i was
in the movie theater because the super
bowl trailer for jason bourne months
earlier had an alternate much cooler
angle of that shot that made my entire
super bowl party go oh
for what it's worth matt and ben's
beloved new england patriots did win the
super bowl that year thanks to malcolm
butler's late game heroics and by that
time in jason bourne's career he had
nothing else to prove he was already the
tom brady of foggy memories spies bourne
is sometimes criticized for its shaky
cam fight scenes but the close quarters
combat of all four demon entries is
nevertheless exciting and brutal
everything from the stairwell battles
and the bourne identity to the vegas
chase and jason bourne get your pulse
pounding but my personal fave is when he
beats up a dude with a magazine go watch
the born supremacy again he dominates a
guy and this guy clearly works out with
a magazine born could even be a lethal
killing machine in a dentist office
waiting room damon proved he could throw
a punch in goodwill hunting and the
elevator seen in the departed is just
all out nuts but he can even make a
fight scene hilarious like when he and
christian bale wrestle on the ground
amid sacks of groceries and curious
neighbors in ford v ferrari it's so
funny and a crucial moment in the film
but damon is equally great in quiet
scenes like at the end of that flick
when he gives bale's son the wrench it's
kleenex worthy stuff
tools are useful because you can make
stuff with them and you can fix stuff
with them
dude
thanks
but i'm not done with fight scenes not
when the singularly focused ass hickory
of ben affleck's the accountant hasn't
been mentioned yet i love the scene
where he defends some nice royal folk
from a would-be assassin he's not quite
jason bourne but he also lacks the
principles of captain tredstone in the
town a movie stacked with the best bank
robbery action this side of point break
i can't decide if i prefer the
non-costumed bank robbery halfway
through the movie or the fenway park
hijacking climax and let's face it ben
affleck great at doing pull-ups in
movies whether it's the traditional
style in the town or he's adding weight
like in batman v superman because when
you're fighting a scary alien from space
i guess make sure your lats are ready
for war say what you will about the dc
snyder burst but what's inarguable is we
got some amazing sequences from the cape
crusader you get his first fight with
superman which doesn't go all that well
for him or his car to the thrilling
postmartha bad guy kill fest dawn of
justice has highlights to spare yet it
still affleck's bruce wayne that has the
most memorable scene for me at the
beginning of that film the audience is
now seeing the climactic battle from man
of steel through the lens of ordinary
bystanders and it's a horror movie mass
destruction in metropolis everybody's
running away from the alien fight
everyone except bruce wayne he runs
towards the chaos into the smoke saving
as many lives as he can giving his
character all the motivation he needs to
load up on kryptonite stock it's an
emotionally overwhelming set piece and
one of the best from any of that wing
freaks movies these boys are far from
just action stars though even in their
biggest blockbusters they can be
vulnerable or emotional or funny
sometimes all in one scene witness the
synapses firing inside the head of
stranded astronaut matt damon the poor
guy just wants to go home or the very
least talk to another human so he has to
make do entertaining us via a camera
feed he hopes is being seen it's
beautiful and heartbreaking in the same
breath or how about a young ben affleck
professing his doomed love in chasing
amy or an older ben quietly accepting
his even more doomed relationship with a
psycho at the end of gone girl as with
every round this one is an
excruciatingly close call so before i
have to render a verdict here can we
just appreciate all the fun sequences
that matt and ben had together on screen
dogma is a veritable hoot from start to
finish whose house runs house and then
roasting each other while on the set of
goodwill hunting two hunting season
inside of kevin smith's j and silent bob
strike back is hysterical but let's not
forget two scenes from the real goodwill
hunting that still hit hard today one
would be affleck going to a meeting
pretending to be will and swiping some
cash as a retainer for the trouble the
other is the often quoted it's not your
fault scene how bad do we all want robin
williams to tell us that
i promise you matt it's not your fault
that this round is also going to ben
affleck from the paint dumping dazed and
confused to the mic drop monologue and
boiler room all the way up to his speech
to alfred in batman v superman compels
me to reason that if there's even a one
percent chance affleck could win this
round then we have to take it as an
absolute certainty
ben gets the win here and we're all tied
up at two to two this is a man who knows
things and now it's time for our wild
card round bro fight well not literally
if bill belichick forbid ben and matt
actually engaged in real fisticuffs i
don't know who'd win they both do action
sequences incredibly well so the
tiebreaker would be the fact that matt
damon is two years older so maybe his
old man strength kicks in a tad more
than ben's
[Applause]
oh what's up you still talk come on but
again it's not what this round is about
no it's a metaphorical fight for
moviegoers here's your scenario you walk
into your favorite multiplex and you
gotta make a decision as to which
theater you're going to enter theater
one has a mystery movie starring matt
damon theater two has a mystery movie
starring ben affleck
and that's mysteries and you have no
other details about this movie not that
it's actually in the mystery genre but i
guess it could be because again it's a
mystery flick we just don't know the
only pieces of information you have is
it it's a brand new release and you
obviously know who stars in the movie so
would you rather see a matt damon film
or one starring ben affleck oh which
theater would i walk into
i'm flattered you asked let's consider
where these fellows are currently at in
their respective careers both are still
making quality entertainment and that's
the good news but if you're like me and
you love jason bourne i'm not betting
that the mystery matt damon movie is
gonna be his fifth one of those there's
always a chance that he returns to that
character but the odds are better that
affleck would be returning to batman i'm
not gonna gamble on either one we have
two dudes who are in their middle-aged
career prime so the movie really could
be anything maybe it's a sports movie
invictus and the way back were about the
same quality in my opinion if it's a
drama starring matt damon it's probably
going to be at least as good as the very
solid stillwater but maybe affleck
directed the movie in which he's
starring so that could be an oscar
contender if it's a comedy i'd have the
same level of enthusiasm and
apprehension both gentlemen very
humorous in the past but they also made
some middling comedies like stuck on you
and jersey girl so it's gonna come down
to which actor would i rather have usher
me through the next two hours of my life
and recently i just tend to get a little
more out of matt damon performances
after a few
efforts he rebounded strong with ford v
ferrari and while ben affleck was very
good in the way back i still have a bad
taste from live by night in my mouth
which he also directed did they even
want to make a real movie or was that
whole production just an excuse to wear
ridiculously oversized suits get a
tailor guys chances are we'll get a good
movie either way and i'm not going to
hold a grudge towards any of you all
that go into theater to affleck as a
matter of fact this whole exercise might
have been pointless because the next
movie either one has coming out is the
last duel which stars both matt damon
and ben affleck and they wrote it too
hey it's like the old times again matt
damon wins the wild card round and thus
the match three to two smash and grab
job huh i don't know what your
reputation is
in this town
but after you tried to pull today you
can bet i'll be looking into you and
that's all for today's episode of versus
matt damon topples his neighbor ben
affleck in a matchup that goes down to
the wire but that's just my opinion now
it's your turn how do you like them
apples
is that really the first time
i said that today do you folks know the
discipline it took to keep that gem
under wraps for five whole rounds hit me
up on social media at mark ellis live
and make sure you're following the
entire team here at rotten tomatoes as
well let us know your take and defend
your answer with bigger until next time
for everyone here at versus i'm mark
ellis
and it's not my fault
[Applause]
you